when observing the natural world many of
us notice a somewhat beautiful dichotomy
no two things are ever exactly alike but
they all seem to follow some underlying
form and Plato believed that the true
forms of the universe were hidden from
us through observation of the natural
world we could merely acquire
approximate knowledge of them they were
hidden blueprints the pure forms were
only accessible through abstract
reasoning of philosophy and mathematics
for example the circle he describes as
that which has the distance from its
circumference to its center everywhere
equal yet we will never find a material
manifestation of a perfect circle or a
perfectly straight line though
interestingly Plato speculated that
after an uncountable number of years the
universe will reach an ideal state
returning to its perfect form this
platonic focus on abstract pure forms
remained popular for centuries and it
wasn't until the sixteenth century when
people try to embrace the messy
variation in the real world and apply
mathematics to tease out underlying
patterns
Bernoulli refined the idea of
expectation he was focused on a method
of accurately estimating the unknown
probability of some event based on the
number of times the event occurs in
independent trials and he uses a simple
example suppose that without your
knowledge 3,000 light pebbles and 2,000
dark pebbles are hidden in an urn and
that to determine the ratio of white
versus black by experiment you draw one
pebble after another with replacement
and note how many times a white pebble
is drawn the key black he went on to
prove that the expected value of white
versus black observations will converge
on the actual ratio as the number of
trials increases known as the weak law
of large numbers and he concluded by
saying if observations of all events be
continued for the entire infinity it
will be noticed that everything in the
world is governed by precise ratios and
a constant law of change this idea was
quickly extended as it was noticed that
not only did things converge on an
expected average but the probability of
variation away from averages also follow
a familiar underlying shape or
distribution a great example of this is
Francis Galton's beam machine imagine
each collision as a single independent
event such as a coin flip and after 10
collisions or events the beam falls into
a bucket representing the ratio of left
versus right deflection or heads versus
tails and this overall curvature known
as the binomial distribution appears to
be an ideal form as it kept appearing
everywhere anytime you look at the
variation of a large number of random
trials
it seems the average fate of these
events is somehow predetermined known
today as the central limit theorem but
this was a dangerous philosophical idea
to some and pavel nekrasov originally a
theology by training later took up
mathematics and was a strong proponent
of the religious doctrine of free will
he didn't like the idea of us having
this predetermined statistical fate and
he made a famous claim that independence
is a necessary condition for the law of
large numbers since independence just
describes these toy examples using beans
or dice where the outcome of previous
events doesn't change the probability of
the current or future events however as
we all can relate most things in the
physical world are clearly dependent on
prior outcomes such as the chance of
fire or Sun or even our life expectancy
and when the probability of some event
depends or is conditional on previous
events we say they are dependent events
or dependent variables so this claim
angered another Russian mathematician
Andrey Markov who maintained a very
public animosity towards nekross off he
goes on to say in a letter that this
circumstance prompts me to explain in a
series of articles that the law of large
numbers can apply to dependent variables
using a construction which he brags
necros off and not even dream about
so Markov extends Bernoulli's results to
dependent variables using an ingenious
construction imagine a coin flip which
isn't independent but dependent on the
previous outcome so it has a short term
memory of one event and this can be
visualized using a hypothetical machine
which contains two cups which we call
States in one state we have a 50-50 mix
of light versus dark beads while in the
other state we have more dark versus
light now one cup we can call state zero
it represents a dark having previously
the other state we can call one it
represents a light beat having
previously occurred now to run our
machine we simply start in a random
state and make a selection and then we
move to either state 0 or 1 depending on
that event and based on the outcome of
that selection we output either a 0 if
it's dark or a 1 if it's light and with
this 2 state machine we can identify 4
possible transitions if we are in state
0 and a black occurs we loop back to the
same state and select again if a light
bead is selected we jump over to state 1
which can also loop back on itself or
jump back to state 0 if a dark is chosen
the probability of a light versus dark
selection is clearly not independent
here since it depends on the previous
outcome but Markov proved that as long
as every state and the machine is
reachable when you run these machines in
a sequence they reach equilibrium that
is no matter where you start once you
begin the sequence the number of times
you visit each state converges to some
specific ratio or probability now this
simple example disapproved necroses
claim that only independent events could
converge on predictable distributions
but the concept of modeling sequences of
random events using States and
transitions between states became known
as a Markov chain and one of the first
and most famous applications of Markov
chains was published by Claude Shannon
you